kiss has been electrifying fans for more
than four decades the band has burned 30
gold records the most in the history of
The Recording Industry Association of
America they gained phase Fame of course
in the 70s for turning rock concerts
into spectacular shows now that group's
glory years are being celebrated in a
new book kiss 1977 to 1980 by
photographer lynn goldsmith we looked
through the portfolio recently with lynn
and kiss frontman gene simmons
[Music]
when photographer lynn goldsmith began
shooting kiss they'd become the biggest
band in the world for kids from New York
Paul Stanley Peter Criss Ace Frehley and
gene Simmons what's going on here
exactly
he's doing his demon thing in full force
he's got his tongue hanging out and he's
showing the most important part of Jason
Anthony it's my job
Goldsmith was a rare breed a female
photographer who'd shot Rock's biggest
stars so she wasn't intimidated by a
fire-breathing bass player in 40 pounds
of armor and seven-inch heels you know
I'm walking in that I'm from Detroit
even though he's incredibly tall he's
not gonna scare me goldsmith found an
unexpected connection with Simmons and
fellow kiss founder Paul Stanley I
really hadn't known any musicians other
than classical ones who were Jewish and
there was this bond immediately she and
Simmons were also both raised by single
mothers this is a photograph of gene and
his mom that I sent to her yeah and then
she sent it back to me well my mother is
Hungarian how is the artist tada mom
it's a band that's right on the photo
taken backstage at Madison Square Garden
in 1977
Simmons mother wrote a note spelling
phonetically the picture was taken with
my darling son fine calm it's kind of
Hebrew and Hungarian put together gene
is my favorite song and then she put in
only Simmons emigrated from Israel with
his mother when he was just 8 and was
quickly captivated by American pop
culture
I started deeply embedding myself in the
world of fantasy comic books and monster
movies and anything that stretched
pounds of reality because I found
reality boring how long does it take you
to get into this makeup two hours that's
how the kiss personas were born but
goldsmith wanted to try something
different I wanted an image of Jean you
know we're doing just pyrotechnics with
this what do you call it Jean here life
threatening kerosene and my Jewish my
house and I did not want it to be in my
studio so I said let's stop here and do
it so you shot this at night on Fifth
Avenue yes yep without a permit she
asked him to take public transportation
and I thought I'd get a reaction from
the bus driver mm-hmm but there was not
nobody said anything to you mm-hmm
nope nobody asked for an autograph
nobody said are you Deacon Simmons
nobody fair okay it's a great photograph
which led to this yes that's at the
Metropolitan Museum Goldsmith made
perhaps her most monumental kiss image
it's a shame they couldn't have left you
there cuz it looks great Thanks
could you tell when you were climbing up
there how good it was gonna look no oh
yes you could have flying no one
manipulates gene gene does exactly
what's gonna benefit gene and kiss
period end of story
commercial break one last photograph
that's gene holding Lynn beckons Wow
the comedy team of Goldsmith and Simmons
they are very funny baby are they should
take it on the road there's a real
legend in that world she's with great
photographer and a real pioneer yes the
fun book have you got a kiss fan in the
family